bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau 7,8 week-end vous le
savez votre émission hebdomadaire dédiée
à l'actualité culture loisirs et sports
de la semaine pendant 26 minutes
au cours de cette émission nous
parlerons idées de sorties avec sylvie
léonard directrice d'yveline tourisme à
l'occasion du lancement de la deuxième
édition de verre les yvelines également
musique au programme avec le premier
festival crazy tonnes à petit vers bâle
grignon avec noémie jolivet et puis tout
au long de l'émission on verra vos
agendas pour le week-end mais place à
yvelines tourisme
je le disais c'est le tout début de la
deuxième édition de verre les yvelines
dans quelques heures qui ouvre ses
portes ce samedi 13 septembre au total
vous pourrez profiter durant trois
week-ends de nombreuses activités de
marge de vélo ou de grand air pour nous
donner l'eau à la bouche en quelque
sorte la directrice divine tourisme est
présente sur le plateau civile à onna
bonsoir à vous ça
tout d'abord première question on va
d'abord voir un petit peu basse et ses
rendez vous immanquable de cette
deuxième édition
quels sont ils alors on commence le
premier rendez vous immanquable c'est
dimanche prochain et cite une grande
randonnée pédestre sur le thème du
médiéval donc c'est une randonnée animée
qui va se dérouler au départ de houdan
donc on va pouvoir faire pour les plus
grandes randonnées 23 km et pour des
randonnées deux demi journées entre 11
et 12 km donc on attend beaucoup de
familles et il ya énormément d'inscrits
il va faire très très bon donc il faut
venir très très nombreux pour la météo
est au rendez-vous ce week-end dans ses
amants câble vous parliez de ces
randonnées il ya aussi d'autres
randonnées au programme énormément en
fin de compte un pendant cette deuxième
en câbles et d'autres handicaps jamais
pas fini oui oui il ya une randonnée
équestre puisqu'on est sur toutes les
pratiques de randonnée à la deuxième
randonnée le 21 donc une semaine après
le dimanche est une grande randonnée
équestre qui va se faire dans la vallée
de chevreuse avec plein d'animations à
la clé
la même façon que pour la pds et puis on
va terminer cette ce grand événement par
le dimanche 28
et là le dimanche 28 ce sera une
randonnée cyclo cette fois ci autour du
pays des impressionnistes je pense qu'on
en a déjà parlé il ya quelques jours le
pays des impressionnistes on pourra
découvrir les bords de seine le musée
fournaise l'île de la chaussée à
bougival plein de parcours qui emprunte
le grand circuit
paris londres qui s'appelle l'avenue
verte donc on a pointé un petit bout de
ceux de ce parcours donc ça va être salé
de super aussi outre ces âmes en kabylie
a évidemment ses trois week-ends 1
pendant vers les yvelines dédié à un
petit peu à tous les marcheurs avec
notamment une superbe balade du côté de
saint germain en laye oui alors on part
de la grande terrasse avec une
magnifique vue sur paris on va aller
dans le parc on va déjeuner dans les
vignes de saint germain il va déguster
le vin des grottes
donc c'est un merveilleux moment à
passer à saint germain il y a en même
temps une randonnée en segway également
à la première étant pédestre et par
rapport à ces randonnées il n'y a pas
que de la marche
il faut aussi il en faut pour tous les
goûts on va pouvoir faire du vtt du côté
de guerville c'est ça et ça s'appelle
bizarrement la guerre vie d'oise alors
on va emprunter tous les grands parcours
vtt de ce coin là on va pouvoir se
mesurer à tous les atouts les parcours
un peu plus difficile c'est vraiment un
grand grand événement du vtt et on
attend énormément de monde également
et la mode aussi cette la marche
nordique oui on peut en faire dans vers
les yvelines cette année c'est ça on va
pouvoir faire de la marche nordique la
marche nordique qu'est ce que c'est donc
on marche avec des bâtons voilà on a la
photo et on fait marcher tous les
muscles c'est en sait beaucoup plus
sportif qu'une marche qu'une marche
classique et donc il y en a une qui est
proposé dans notre événement vers les
ibis une randonnée que j'ai que gekko
chez moi sur mon agenda c'est au nautic
parquet un petit peu le concept de la
randonnée sur l'eau on peut appeler ça
comme ça
oui alors déjà qu'est ce que le nautic
parc le nautic parc c
une espèce de sites de loisirs sur l'eau
qui est à bougival et devant lille de la
chaussée et on peut faire des randonnées
en zodiac alors il ya le baptême en
zodiac la plus grande randonnée en
zodiac pendant ce temps les enfants peut
le faire peuvent faire du petit pédalo
tout un tas d'activités qui leur sont
réservées donc c'est vraiment un
événement à ne pas manquer surtout s'il
fait beau puisque il ya des randonnées
en zodiac qui sont programmées tous les
week-ends de notre événement vers les
yvelines
on ne peut pas évidemment découvrir les
yvelines en se baladant sans découvrir
versailles
c'est ça alors versailles c'est une
randonnée à pied ou randonnée à vélo on
prend sa feuille de route à versailles
garder chantier puisqu'il faut rappeler
que le principe de notre événement c'est
de faire partir les randonnées dans la
mesure du possible d'une gare sncf pour
que nos amis les parisiens puissent
venir nous rejoindre en train et puis
ensuite pratiquer leur randonnée et
reprendre le train sans avoir pris leur
véhicule et donc on est partenaire de la
sncf sur ce sur cette opération
donc à versailles on prend sa petite
feuille de route on va dans le dans le
parc on passe par la cour des senteurs
le nouvel cours des senteurs le potager
du roi et on découvre la vie de royal un
petit peu différemment de l'habitude
autre randonnée pédestre du côté de
bazoches sur guyonne christian sur
wilson alors c'est pas loin de montfort
l'amaury c'est un petit coin de campagne
des petits villages un peu un peu
médiévaux il ya plein de choses à
découvrir il ya notamment la maison de
jean monnet perdent l'europe avoir c'est
celle que l'on voit à l'écran et il y a
une maison d'architecte la maison louis
carré qui est aussi à voir et donc on
randonne dans ce magnifique village en
découvrant également les petits l'avoir
de l'époque
voilà c'est ça vous transporte un peu
hors du temps et puis pour ceux qui sont
couche tard il ya là la randonnée le
tuant du côté du méné saint denis donc
c'est en vallée de chevreuse et là on
est avec sa lampe frontale et on
découvre les différents lieux où ont
lieu les tournages de films avec des
petites surprises gourmands
des projections de courts métrages en
même temps voilà ça va être une belle
soirée
et enfin pour terminer ce beau programme
vous pourrez prendre votre vélo par
exemple pour aller dans la vallée de
chevreuse sur les traces de jean racine
je crois oui alors c'est la société
cycle hollande qui propose ça donc on va
dans la vallée de chevreuse
on prend son vtt sur le circuit jean
racine en découvre évidemment les sites
qui qui existe dans la vallée de
chevreuse les jolis paysages mais aussi
7 cette société propose une autre une
autre randonnée à vtt qui part du parc
du château de versailles et qui va
jusqu'aux étangs de la minière donc de
belles randonnées en perspective pour
les vététistes comme les avais je km a
dévalé pas très bien donc rendez vous
pour les téléspectateurs un petit peu
partout dans les yvelines si on n'a rien
oublié à partir de ce samedi 13
septembre jusqu'au 28 septembre prochain
merci vous connaissez le vide est
repassé sur le 7-8 week-end à très
bientôt
autre idée de balade originale à
l'espace rambouillet et ce jusqu'au 4
octobre prochain vous pourrez écouter le
brame du cerf chaque année à la saison
des amours le ser lance ce cri de l'aube
à la tombée de la nuit pour montrer sa
suprématie envers les femelles attention
une visite toutefois guider mais
uniquement sur réservation l'univers
bervet di rosa entre à la maison elsa
triolet d'aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines pionnier de
l'art modeste hervé di rosa y présente
ses oeuvres numériques et sculptures
issues des cultures populaires
aurélia de bissy et elodie moi c'est
dans le sud est divine que font escale
nigaud et autres rené les personnages
récurrents de l'artiste hervé di rosa
jusqu'au 25 novembre la maison elsa
triolet aragon un lieu de patrimoine ou
vert à création contemporaine propose de
découvrir un autre aspect du travail de
l'artiste la peinture numérique des
oeuvres réalisées à partir d'un
ordinateur puis imprimé pour
l'exposition sur des toiles c'est une
cette nouvelle je dirais de son travail
puisqu'il a commencé les hommes
numérique en 2010 et là vraiment il
utilise l'ordinateur comme on utilise un
pinceau une palette et ils crèvent
vraiment de façon informatique toutes
les oeuvres et après on projette où on
imprime voilà on donne une vie à
l'oeuvre donc là ce sont des toiles mais
ça pourrait être des projections puisque
ce sont des oeuvres finalement
immatériel des oeuvres colorées et
graphique inspiré de la bande dessinée
dans lesquels on retrouve le peuple des
rené figure emblématique du monde
d'hervé di rosa
il n'avait pas utilisé les rené depuis
des années puisqu'elle réapparaissent
l'a récemment dans son oeuvre est en
fait c'est l'homme de tous les jours qui
est dans des situations
du quotidien mais toujours de façon
loufoque coloré est vraiment tout le
monde se retrouve en fait dans ces
personnages là en fait est une oeuvre
que je trouve très intéressante seger
narcos parce que là on voit à la fois
comment ils utilisent l'histoire de
l'art avec ce clin d'oeil à guernica de
picasso est à la fois ce côté bande
dessinée que l'on retrouve dans l'oeuvre
qu'on va retrouver dans des images
contemporaines
une démarche artistique qui s'inscrit
dans le prolongement de la figuration
libre
l'art modeste comme le qualifie hervé di
rosa un art qui dépasse les frontières
de jambes sans hiérarchie de valeurs
entre haute et basse culture
l'exposition de peintures numériques et
de sculptures qui a déjà accueilli plus
de 6000 visiteurs depuis le 17 mai est
prolongé jusqu'au 25 novembre
après l'art place à la musique j'en
parlais dans les titres de cette édition
ce samedi 13 septembre vous allez
pouvoir découvrir un tout nouveau
festival le premier en son genre le
crazy tonnes festival attire val grignon
et pour nous présenter cet événement
noémie mme jolivet co organisatrice est
présente sur le plateau bonjour à vous
merci d'être là alors pour essayer de
découvrir un petit peu pour les
téléspectateurs c'est c'est la première
édition cette année en 2014
en quoi ça consistait alors en fait ça
va commencer demain à partir de 17
heures et il va y avoir en fait une
programmation très éclectique graff un
concert donc ça passera de la chanson
française au reggae au blues au rock ou
en passant par la world music
donc il y en a pour tous les goûts en
fait et il y aura à boire à manger et
tout ce qu'il faut et comment il est le
projet d'un festival à thiverval grignon
bon en fait il est né de la
collaboration entre deux associations de
la ville de timmins mal grignon donc
para siempre qui est une association un
collectif de musiciens qui jouent de la
musique plutôt latino et black boomerang
qui est une association qui joue plutôt
de la musique rock est en fait ces deux
associations ont décidé de créer ce
festival pour la première fois dans un
village qui leur est cher et dans un
lieu particulier qui est le site de
folleville vous avez la chance il va
sûrement faire très beau ce week-end
c'est un festival en plein air pour le
rappeler aux téléspectateurs vous disiez
musique très éclectique 1 pour citer
quelques artistes présents manon landry
qui qui va être qui est une chanteuse
atomique frogs qui font du rock il
l'aura du reggae avec squale ray et les
bandes difficile de faire cohabiter un
peu tout le monde comme ça c'est pour
pour essayer de tout souci c'est plutôt
pour essayer de plaire à tout le monde
ben je crois que oui c'est pour pour que
tout le monde s'y retrouve
et du coup c'est plus enrichissant en
fait de pouvoir mélanger tous les styles
de musique au même endroit et dans un
bien particulier ce sont des artistes
locaux disent chinois pour la plupart
oui exactement des sons deviennent tous
des yvelines oui et est-ce que ça a été
difficile de mettre en place un festival
parce qu'il y en a quand même beaucoup à
cette période de l'année il y en a à
chevreuse dont je parlerai un petit peu
plus tard il y en a un petit peu partout
c'est compliqué à mettre en place aux
fermes logistique par exemple
heureusement fait que nous avons est un
grand soutien de la ville 2-1 malgré
nous grâce à qui nous avons pu faire
tout ça et on a eu beaucoup de bénévoles
aussi ce qui nous a permis d'alléger la
logistique et voilà de bien préparer
tout ça pour demain
c'est aussi une occasion peut être un
petit festival entre guillemets un sens
sans faire injure à crayton c'est
l'occasion pour ces jeunes groupes de ba
de faire leurs preuves aussi sur scène
de se faire connaître peut-être oui
alors ce sont quand même tous des
groupes qui ont déjà joué qui ont déjà
fait de multiples scènes mais oui oui
c'est pour ça aussi et on espère
peut-être l'année prochaine faire
accueillir encore plus de groupes et
encore plus de monde
par rapport à ce festival et comment
cela va se passer c'est entrée gratuite
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure c'est dans
un espace en dehors de la ville sait où
c'est une sorte de fête de la musique
les concerts vont durer longtemps ou se
cumulent et comment ça va se passer
alors en fait c'est sur le site de
folleville qui est un endroit un peu
particulier au milieu des champs un peu
à part de la ville en fête et dans
lequel il ya beaucoup de potentiel pour
ce genre de festival donc en plein air
va pouvoir avoir ces cinq concerts en
mangeant quelque chose voilà avec un
atelier graff aussi avec un tagueur qui
sera là pour yacco qu'ils seraient là
pour pour vous divertir les festivaliers
très bien donc si vous voulez découvrir
un peu tous ces types et ces genres de
musique du blues de la musique du monde
du reggae ou encore du rock et bien
rendez vous ce samedi 13 septembre à
partir de 17 heures pour ce premier créé
easy tone festival à thiverval grignon
sur le site de folleville merci beaucoup
si les mid est repassé sur le 7-8
week-end et on suivra ça évidemment de
près vous pourrez découvrir un autre
festival j'en parlais il y à quelques
minutes ce week-end du côté de chevreuse
le festival magnifique
vous pourrez assister à des concerts des
spectacles des arbres eu encore des
animations pour les enfants et avec en
prime une soirée brésilienne ce vendredi
soir
allez on passe aux sports pour terminer
ce set 8 week-end et du tennis de table
cette semaine les féminines d'elancourt
ont fait leurs grands débuts en pro a le
championnat france l'élite du tennis de
table le national si le maintien sera
une mission délicate
cette année les championnes de france de
pro b trépigner d'impatience à l'idée de
se confronter aux poids lourds de
l'équipe nationale reportage elles
n'attendent que ça pour leur premier
match en pro a
les joueuses d'elancourt auront le droit
à un baptême xxl puisque les filles de
franck soulier se déplace chez lys
lannoy tout simplement le vice-champion
de repentis on est impatient de voir un
peu ce que c'est que ce championnat 3
sans prétention ce que le championnat va
être très dur mais ouais on a d'être
marni déjà là on parle que de ça en fin
de compte là il ya vraiment une envie de
faire quelque chose et d'aller chercher
le maintien puisque c'est l'objectif de
l'équipe cette année
dans ce championnat pour décrocher son
maintien et après le départ d'anne
sophie jean et l'encours a fait venir
l'expérimenté slovène biljana todorovic
la médaillée de bronze aux championnats
d'europe 2005 avait déjà rencontré le
club en pro b sous les couleurs de
quimper
alors quand le cet été elle a contacté
cet été à 36 ans la nouvelle doyenne de
l'équipe n'a pas hésité très longtemps
itunes un gosse j'ai choisi et l'on
court parce que l'équipe et l'esprit
d'équipé c'est pour moi le plus
important c'est cette force qui nous
permettra de gagner des matches et j'ai
logiquement trouver ma place ici pour la
première fois de son histoire le club va
évoluer dans l'élite du tennis de table
français seul eva odorova et biljana
todorovic connaissent les joutes du
championnat de france
à 35 ans la capitaine et l'on courtoise
entame sa 13e saison de croix et fait
office de guide
c'est par là que pas avec les filles
parce que c'est vrai que l'année
dernière par exemple
c'étaient eux qui m'ont parlé un petit
peu de joueuses de pro b parce que je
n'ai pas connu est cette saison ça cela
plutôt moi j'essaie d'en avec ans et
j'essaye leur dire comment qu'on se
fasse pas se sentir différent par
rapport à la pro b
le mélange entre jeunesse et expérience
sont en tout cas pétiller reste à le
faire exploser face au champion de
france en titre mardi soir en ouverture
du championnat mais au palais des sports
en fin septembre face au kremlin bicêtre
autre rendez vous pour ce week-end plus
proche dans l'agenda au niveau sport ce
dimanche vous allez pouvoir découvrir le
stock car avec le super stock car 2014
pour vous résumer la chose sur une piste
ovale de 200 m qui pourrait servir pour
trois ou quatre voitures en temps normal
vont s'élancer entre 15 et 25 véhicules
dans 11.1 bouteille âge monstrueux et
permanent les pilotes vont devoir
effectuer 20 tours le plus rapidement
possible rendez vous donc ce dimanche à
garancière à partir de 15h autre rendez
vous sportifs du week-end du baseball et
vous pourrez supporter les cougars ce
samedi tout d'abord pour le compte des
demi finales de division 2 de baseball
ce sont les playoffs montigné reçoit
l'équipe fédérale et n'a plus le droit à
l'erreur pour se hisser en finale
premier match donc samedi à 16 heures
il y aura aussi du forum des
associations encore si vous n'avez pas
encore trouvé de club pour votre enfant
ou vous même vous pourrez aller vous
renseigner ce samedi 13 septembre au
forum des associations de magny les
hameaux de 10 heures à 17 heures au
gymnase
chantal mauduit allez on termine par
notre page cinéma
avant de nous quitter un petit coup
d'oeil sur les salles obscures pour ce
week-end si vous cherchez une idée de
sortie au cinéma cette semaine c'est luc
beaucoup en directeur du ciné 7
d'elancourt qui nous délivre son coup de
coeur alors beaucoup de coeur de la
semaine c'est le dernier film du
réalisateur canadien denis villeneuve et
demi avec une nouvelle fois jack guina
aulas qui l'avait déjà fait tourner dans
prisoners qui était son précédent film
qui était lui-même précédé du très bon
incendie donc là on est dans un thriller
mais qui est très différente prisoners
est un thriller plutôt fantastique et
psychologiques qui parle d'une histoire
de sosies mais c'est très prenant ses
traits réussissent leur honneur et une
nuits et il est projeté cette semaine
sur nos écrans donc en vf et en vo comme
ça vous aurez le choix voilà le film est
aussi interprétée par l'actrice
française mélanie laurent
un film à aller voir assurément c'est la
fin de ce sept huit week-ends merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end sur tv fille